this is incredible [__] my life I'm
gonna drop some truth bombs here listen
the whale is not a masterpiece it's a
joyless harmful fantasy of fat squalor
the Oscar nomination for the whale must
mean it's great right wrong to shallow
and stigmatized reflection of thin
people's assumptions about fat bodies oh
my God is it written by some fire yeah
yeah there we go obviously
I mean yeah I hadn't planned on engaging
with the whale in fact one of my fat
friends and I joke
all it needed was for her to capitalize
the word fat and I joked extensively
about how much we were not under any
circumstances going to shine our fat
little light on the whale no disrespect
to the fat writers who chose to do so
what do you notice how like being fat is
now an identity yeah yeah yeah yeah
absolutely like they're proud of being
fat yeah exactly you know they're gonna
campaign to get it uh capitalized so
every time you use the word fat
well so that it reflects the fact that
they're massive yeah however I changed
my mind about watching the whale when
another friend a thin one so you can
take him seriously texted me fresh out
of a pre-release screening that he was
one of the worst stupidest movies he'd
seen in years well now I was intrigued
because I like putting garbage in my
mouth and head the thought of gilded
Academy voters weeping over a video
Fraser in a fat suit choking on a
meatball sub gave me strange pleasure of
course he didn't have food in it
the joke suddenly was on them Licious
keto sandwich sprayed with ranch
dressing a meal that no wonder you're
five you think that's delicious I mean
all that the world's protagonist eats
while crying Standing Ovation low you
idiots I've been writing about being fat
begging for my Humanity to be seen for
Anton hide this I'm gonna drop some
truth bombs here listen if you're
massive and fat no one is not seeing
your Humanity because it's there in
front of us wobbling it's right there no
one is not seeing your Humanity right we
see you because you're there everywhere
you are literally everywhere
this is incredible [__] my life smaller
fat people have a few more clothing
options Weight Watchers has rebranded to
pretend it isn't a diet program oh no a
diet program the structural oppression
of fat people what
substandard medical care we spend way
more on your medical care than the
average person lower salaries or maybe
we should hire some fat people
save some money Anton can you put some
weight on me we'll take your salary
maybe it's unfair to use one independent
film as the barometer for an entire
society's attitudes towards fat people
she's starting to get it yeah maybe it's
a straw man argument to accuse one fat
character of being a stand-in for people
but I'm gonna do it yeah but as a
professional fat person
what
what the [__] is a professional fat
person it's someone who's a fatty
professionally you get paid for being
fat mate do you oh she is that's what it
means to be a professional
I was an amateur fatty yeah you were I
just you did a good job of it yeah I Did
It For The Love yeah but for the food
yeah exactly For the Love of food for
the love of food right but she's a
professional she sits there shoving
meatball sub in the face yeah even
though she doesn't want to eat late at
night because she's in training she's
like I gotta turn up to the guardian
tomorrow and if I lose a little bit of
weight what are they going to say
exactly this is my unique point of view
yeah exactly being a chunker here we go
I can say that because I used to be fat
do you know what I actually used to be
fat did you when I was a kid I was fat
yeah yeah because I used to eat a lot
and not do any sport yeah exactly and
then I got sent to a British boarding
school yeah and the food was [__] and
they made you do tons of exercise and
then I wasn't fat anymore yeah because
it wasn't a gland problem it was eating
too much being a fat [__] problem yeah
and then I solved it with British food
then people hate us so much that this is
what it looks like when they're trying
to like us Anton
oh
I've been thin other than a couple of
bouts of fatness yeah for my entire life
I have never hated fat people no
I fat shamed you because I'm your friend
and I want you to be healthy yeah and it
worked and now your thin healthy and
miserable exactly right don't even eat
sugar anymore the result we were trying
to achieve Charlie is a fictional
character in a movie there's a fictional
character in the movie and this idea
that they're trying to create that they
are somehow the new oppressed minority
you're not you're just fat yeah you eat
too much and you don't exercise enough
there are people who have to take
steroids and whatever else there's women
who've got conditions aren't polycystic
ovaries with syndrome which means that
it's very difficult for them to lose
weight
etc etc etc but for a lot of people it's
because they have an unhealthy diet and
they don't have a life which is high in
high physical activity and even though
there is obviously the argument that in
a society with socialized Healthcare
like the one that we have obesity is a
big problem for which we're all paying
and I think that's true I am someone who
believes in people's freedom to do
whatever they want including things that
are bad for them yeah right and I defend
people's right to be overweight if
that's what they choose to be what I
object to is a pretending that you're
some kind of [__] victim would you
not and B the normalization of it is if
it's something healthy it's not healthy
to be fat no sorry it's not it's just
not and the thing that I find very
interesting is so she was almost framing
herself as this MLK like figure who was
talking about the struggle there is no
[__] struggle there is getting
upstairs yeah yeah putting your pants on
look I am never going gonna protect I'm
I'm never going to stop making fun of
the [__] because I understand